a couple of videos ago we figured out
how to go from the empirical formula
from the empirical formula formula to
the mass composition and all I mean by
that mass composition is that you can
start with the empirical formula h2o
which is also its molecular formula and
then we were able to figure out what
percentage of this was water and what
percentage of this was hydrogen the way
we did it is we said okay oxygens mass
is 16 atomic mass units hydrogen is 1
the mass of the entire molecule is 2
times hydrogen 2 times 1 plus 16 for
that one oxygen so it's 18 and then we
said the composition of oxygen is just
16 over 18 so oxygen is 16 over 18 and
if I I don't have my calculator anymore
I think the number was something on the
order of 88 percent or 88.9% 88.9%
oxygen so now let's see if we can go the
other way let's see if we could start
with mass composition mass composition
the percent composition of the different
elements and then go to empirical
formula empirical formula and I think
the first video I made I spelled
empirical wrong which which is good
reason for me not to do spelling videos
I think I spelled this with an e right
here because I pronounced it empirical
but it's spelled with an i empirical
formula so back to the empirical formula
so let's do some I guess we could call
it some exercises here to see if we can
if we can get someplace so let's say
that I start off with something I need
space my periodic table is right down
there let's say I am told that I have a
a bag of stuff and 75% of that bag 75%
of that bag let's say it is mercury
mercury HG and tens the other 25% of the
bag is chlorine chlorine so my question
or the question that I'm asked is what
is the empirical formula of the stuff
that I have here
zooming that it's all one molecule or
one type of molecule so what is the
empirical formula empirical formula
formula what is it so the way to think
about this is just assume I don't know
let's assume you have a hundred grams of
this stuff all right I'm the reason why
I'm picking 100 is because 100 is a
useful number to deal with so if I have
a hundred grams of the stuff all right
so let's say I assume assume that you
have a hundred grams a hundred grams if
you have a hundred grams how many grams
of mercury do you have well that means
that you have 75 percent of that that
means you have 75 grams of mercury HG
and that means you have 25 grams 25
grams of chlorine you might be saying
where do you get these numbers from you
know the percentage doesn't necessarily
well it I got the numbers cuz I assumed
100 grams I could have assumed 112 grams
or seven grams but those would have been
harder numbers to work with so I'm just
assuming a hundred grams so the question
is in 75 grams of mercury how many moles
of mercury do I have so I need to
convert from grams to moles so let me
let's go the other way one mole of
mercury this is at least how my brain
thinks let me suitable color so one mole
of mercury so 6.02 times 10 to the 23
mercury atoms what's the mass of that
well it's equal to whatever Mercury's
mass number is in grams so let's go look
up Mercury's mass number so mercury is a
transition metal it's one of the few
metals that are liquid and at room
temperature right there
we have mercury its mass number let's
pick the 200 it has a mass number of 200
obviously there's some mercury out there
that has a mass of 201 but for this for
simplicity let's say it's 200 so the
homework where I was I
pure so one mole of mercury is 200 grams
200 grams how did I get that Mercury's
mass number one atom of mercury has a
mass of 200 atomic mass units so one
mole of mercury 6.02 times 10 to 23
mercury atoms has that many grams of
mass so instead of 200 atomic mass units
per atom we have 200 grams per mole of
that atom it was an easy calculation you
just look up its atomic mass number and
say it's that many grams and you have a
mole of the substance fair enough and
what about one mole one mole of chlorine
well we do the same exercise we go down
to our periodic table chlorine has a
mass number of let's say 35 it has
various isotopes on this planet but
let's say the mass number is 35 so one
chlorine atom weighs well now it
shouldn't say weighs have to be very
careful one chlorine atom has a mass of
35 atomic mass units so 6.02 times 10 to
the 23 chlorine atoms or 1 mole of
chlorine atoms will have a mass of I
already forgot my number was it 35 35
grams so how many moles how many moles
of mercury do I have let me get my
calculator going so I have 75 grams of
mercury 1 mole of mercury would have a
mass of 200 grams so I could just take
75 divided by 200 and tells me how many
moles I have 75 divided by 200 is equal
to that's actually I shouldn't be able
to do that so I have 37.5 moles or 0.375
moles 0.375 moles of mercury how did I
figure that 1 mole of mercury would be
200 grams I only have 75 grams of
mercury so I have a small fraction of it
roughly 0.375 moles of mercury that's
I've just expressed a number of atom
of mercury I have moles tells me is 6.02
times 10 to the 23 so atoms of mercury
so I have point three seven five times
Avogadro's number of mercury atoms fair
enough now let's do the chlorine I have
25 grams of chlorine one mole of
chlorine is 35 grams so I have 25 over
35 moles so what's that so 25 divided by
35 is equal to seventy one point four
seventy one point four point seven one
four so it's equal to 0.7 one four moles
of chlorine okay now these numbers
they're not exact because if you take
twice this number up here you don't get
twice this number right here you don't
you if you get twice this you don't get
this but this is roughly I have to
roughly twice as many moles of chlorine
as I do of mercury so that tells me that
for every mercury I don't remember moles
is just a number for every mercury atom
I have I have two chlorine atoms so the
empirical formula here is for every
mercury I have two chlorines I have two
chlorines right there and the numbers
didn't work out almost exactly right I
mean it's it's not it's not you know and
especially in the real world when you're
actually trying to figure out things
empirically your numbers seldom will and
maybe there's some random other things
running out there in terms of other
things that are contributing to the mass
but this is close enough to know that
the ratio of mercury to chlorine is
roughly 1 to 2 right for every you know
this is a number for every one chlorine
atom you have roughly two this is you
have twice as many I guess the other way
of thinking about is you have twice as
many chlorine atoms in the bag as you
have mercury roughly although this is a
little bit more this is close to 0.75
but it's close enough for you to know
that you're dealing with mercury
chloride right there let's do another
one of these
let's see how the numbers turn out for
this one let's say you have another bag
another bag that is 9 percent magnesium
9 percent magnesium and let's say the
remainder of the bag let's say the
remainder of the bag 91% is iodine 91%
is Ida so the way to do all of these is
you should do the same thing assume you
have 100 grams so if you have 100 grams
of which you have 9 grams of magnesium
and you have 91 grams of iodine and then
figure out how much what of a mole of
magnesium what would be the mass of a
mole of magnesium in a mole of iodine so
let me write here mole one mole of
magnesium and we want to figure out one
mole of iodine one mole of iodine let's
figure those out so magnesium's mass
number is let's say let's just go with
24 let's say we have the isotope this 24
magnesium is 24 and since we're already
down here what's iodine 127 its 127
iodine is one of the halogens iodine so
let's see you have a 127 and you have 24
let me write those down so you have 127
and you had 24 alright I have a bad
memory too so it was in magnesium right
24 so these are there one atom of iodine
has an atomic mass number or has a mass
of 127 atomic mass units so a whole mole
of it 6.02 times 10 to 23 iodine atoms
will have a mass of 127 grams you just
take the atomic you just take the atomic
weight or the atomic mass and say it has
that many the the mass will do that many
grams when you have this many of the
atom so and then one mole of magnesium
will be 24 grams so now we just figure
out how many moles of each of these we
have we have 9 grams of magnesium so
what fraction of
that is a mold is 24 grams so this is
equal to 9
24th of magnesium and what is 9 to over
24 9 divided by 24 is equal to 0.375 so
this is equal to 0.375 which is similar
to what we had in the last problem with
that 0.375 showed up and 91 grams of
iodine is what 91 grams of iodine well
in a whole mole of iodine you're gonna
have a hundred 27 grams so we have we
have 91 over 127 moles of iodine and
what's 91 over 127 I have a feeling
we're gonna have very similar numbers
121 divided by 127 is equal to 0.7 1/6
so this one turned out I should do
another problem with better ratios than
this these have the same ratios as the
last problem 0.71 0.72 roughly moles
moles of iodine this is moles of
magnesium so we have roughly twice the
number of iodine atoms as we do of
magnesium atoms right for every one
magnesium atom we have roughly two ions
I know this isn't exactly one or two but
it's pretty close so the formula here is
magnesium iodide right there and that's
the empirical formula we don't know
maybe there would have been maybe in
every atom maybe had two magnesium's and
four iodine's we don't know we all we
know is that the ratio of magnesium to
iodine here is one to two in the next
video I'm gonna try to look for ones
that have more interesting ratios
because I don't want to do two problems
that both have the same ratio but
hopefully you found this a little bit
helpful